kochi  it was a name that sounded so sweet so  seductive come meet the family the  guccis were one of the famous dynasties  in italy the entire family was in this  toxic war over who is going to claim the  throne  mauricio gucci and paolo gucci are the  two sons of  aldo and rodolfo who both took the  company from guccio gucci and started to  expand  kochi is what i say peace as long as we  are 50 50 that's how it stays i would  describe them as not a happy family  which is not exciting and everybody  knows it at least it's my name sweetie  our name  sweetie  [Music]  when patricia came into the family  things started to change  at that point everybody in the gucci  family becomes seduced by power and  pride gucci is my name too some of the  characters are so far on the other side  of the line it's crazy it's time to take  out the trash  [Music]  ultimately you have one side of the  family that wins  and another  that loses  [Music]  [Music]  you